welcome to another dr sadler's honest
book review this is a series in which i
provide unvarnished and in depth and
detail reviews of recent works mostly in
philosophy but in connected fields as
well so understanding philosophy rather
broadly to include cultural criticism
ethics critical thinking
leadership studies personal development
and all sorts of other things today i'm
doing something a bit different i am
reviewing
this book which is actually coming out
today this is an advanced copy that i
got of it verissimos meaning most
truthful the subtitle is the stoic
philosophy
of marcus aurelius and it is by two
people donald robertson the author the
the one who's putting words into the
mouths of the characters and then an
illustrator uh jay nuno fraga
who
collaborated with donald to produce this
really quite beautiful
volume
and it is uh really quite something to
look at but i'll tell you all about that
as we go through the style and structure
main points good things and problematic
aspects and then wrap up with some final
thoughts
i always begin these book reviews by
talking about three s's that is a
summary of the work the style of the
work and the structure of the work and
here i think you know when we talk about
style and structure the fact that it is
a graphic novel
really is you know of central importance
there are these chapter headings like
the one you see here the most truthful
child and each of these chapter headings
begins with a quotation from marcus
aurelius
and you know then has this gorgeous
beautiful
you know comic style thing with thought
bubbles and narration
and words being exchanged between people
and you know as it is with graphic
novels much of what is happening takes
place through the dialogue between the
characters or their interior monologue
so you know it's it's a sequential
you could say
novelization
of the life but also the lessons and the
thought
of
marcus aurelius one of the
good emperors there weren't a hell of a
lot of them of rome and also a
stoic philosopher
who left behind not only a lot of deeds
and words as part of his legacy that
other people recorded
but
a very popular book
it's one that's that's quite often
read as sort of a representative of
stoicism which we typically translate as
meditations but is actually
written
to himself
and so
that plays a really central role in this
i would say you know so it's called the
stoic philosophy of marcus aurelius
and one of the main goals of robertson
and his illustrator
is to
get across some of the
key ideas some of the key teachings of
stoic philosophy so you're going to see
seneca brought up and
actually not mentioned as such really
although some of his ideas are being
used and then epictetus and others as
well
so there's a lot of putting
things coming from stoic literature into
the
mouths of characters for example
teachers philosophical teachers that
marcus himself is going to have as
important in his life
and there's a lot of really cool
vignettes we could call them uh where we
see
something
being talked about being illustrated so
here's a here's a great uh image right
here where the emperor
himself is afraid of of death but
there's a great one in here with
hercules
there's others where
other interesting things are going on so
here is a depiction
of
the the storm tossed boat at sea
and the stoic
sage or you know wise person or
philosopher at least who is
you know showing fear to some degree in
this case it's um apollonius of
chelseadon the professor of stoicism who
teaches in athens and so there's lots of
interesting little sections like that
that kind of break it up
there are a number of different
[Music]
chapters that are focusing on particular
themes and topics if you look at the
table of contents it kind of runs you
through
what is actually
going on in this you know the most
truthful child the stoic master the
emperor's faustina the legend the
legionary legate the parthian war the
temple of apollo the antonine plague we
could go on and on and on and each of
these is detailing
something important that is taking place
a lot of these are uprisings and wars
that marcus himself has to be involved
in
and it winds up you know ending with
this the view from above now i should
also mention when it comes to
uh structure that there
is a preface to it
and you know donald is is talking here
about
uh his process and the work that he did
and how he ended up
collaborating with this young portuguese
illustrator
jay noona fraga
he says the book isn't intended as an
introduction of stoic philosophy how to
think like a roman emperor and stoicism
the art of happiness do that quite well
instead we choose to do something
completely new by
presenting marcus's philosophical
precepts and psychological techniques in
a more concrete way
placing them within the context of real
live events from his life we show how
stoicism influenced some of his
decisions as roman emperor and helped
him to cope with the many challenges he
faced
there is also
two other things towards the end of the
book there's an appendix
which has to do with anger and then
there is
an afterword as well and these are both
pretty short
they don't you know detract from the
structure of the work which is mostly
all graphic novel so that's probably
enough by way of talking about the three
s's
what are some of the key ideas now i'm
not going to do a run through of all the
different stoic concepts and practices
that are coming up in this instead what
are some of the key
ideas in the work itself
the one thing i'll say to begin with is
the work begins after we get past you
know uh the the preliminary stuff in the
table of contents with an emperor dying
the year is 180 a.d the emperor marcus
aurelius lies dying of plague in the
legionary camp at vindobana in the roman
province of pannonia and here we we see
him in his bed coughing spitting up
blood dying and what do we have at the
very end of the work in addition to this
beautiful
uh
set of
plates
that are the view from above
just before that
we have the emperor
who is on his last legs
coming back
uh paying mem respect to his mem memory
of his his tutor
and in in a crypt
um and that's that's essentially where
it's
ending right we have the full cycle of
marcus aurelius's life and some of the
most important
things that happened
in it um
we start the narrative itself with
little marcus getting called verissimus
the title of the book by his grandfather
and
starting on a path a path of moral
goodness of earnestness of taking on the
responsibilities that are thrust upon
him in order to try to make the
immediate surroundings and the people
he's in charge of and then the roman
empire itself and even the world itself
a better place
and we get to see his character
coming through significantly i would say
in the storytelling that's going on now
as i mentioned already a significant
part of this
as was a significant part of marcus
aurelius's life
is concerned with conflict with wars
with
dealing with crises so you know who does
he face who does rome face well the
parthians are a big part of that the you
know resurgent persian empire that is
jockeying with rome over mesopotamia
and armenia uh and and other you know
syria other border lands
a significant part of the the warfare is
going on there we also have the
sarmatians who are descended supposedly
from the scythians and other war-like
people and then we could say taking the
greatest place
until of course the civil war that's
going to happen
we have the germans various german
tribes a number of them some of whom
rome is allied with some of whom are
enemies of rome and they are up there on
the northern and western frontiers and
there's you know
there's a lot of decisions that have to
be made can we deal with this issue over
here well we have to pull troops from
here and then these people over here
start to see us as easy prey
complicating it even more
one of the things that comes back from
persia
is a
plague a pestilence a pandemic that
begins to ravage
people throughout the roman empire and
in other places as well
there is also
several you know characters who play a
major role
marcus has a brother lucius who's kind
of a screw-up and he tries to make him
effectively co-emperor
and that's really not working out
because lucius not only doesn't have the
talent for it he doesn't have the guts
he doesn't have the drive he doesn't
have the care of other people he's
interested mostly in drinking and
enjoying himself and bossing people
around and then we have a
noble
you know very competent military
commander ovidus cassius who eventually
will
effectively start a civil war taking
uh parts of the roman empire and
declaring himself
the you know the ruler of those well
marcus is
still alive but perhaps you know avidis
doesn't cassius doesn't know this so
there's questions about all this so we a
lot of this is concerned with the
battlefield and what's going on and we
get to see
the
horrors of war not just those that are
being imposed by these barbarians
but what the romans themselves also do
as well there's even a tower
where all these uh german men are you
know lashed to it and it is set on fire
to try to show the germans that you
better not mess with rome
which you know certainly makes an
impression
you know we see roman rulers as
themselves tyrants driven by their
passions particularly
that of anger but also driven by their
fears as well an exception to this would
be antonius who
marcus uh is is you know
being brought up by
we see here this is part of it antonius
differed from hadrian in almost every
way his next act was to make the
succession clearer by naming me caesar
and betrothing his youngest daughter
faustina to me he was cheerful and
easygoing the senate loved him because
he treated them with respect and
willingly shared power with them
he showed me that even in a palace one
could live simply and unpretentiously
he says remove these statues and other
ornaments from my room dismiss the
guards i won't be needing them
marcus goes on he deliberated carefully
taking his time over important matters
however once he was satisfied with his
decision he would act with great focus
and determination he neither flattered
others nor sought to win praise himself
no one would ever dream of calling him a
sophist unlike hadrian who is
pretentious flippant and pedantic
he welcomed criticism and always
listened patiently to the opinions of
those with more wisdom and experience
despite being emperor he never
considered himself superior to anyone
else
reassured by his example i therefore
resolved to become antonius's disciple
in all things
both as a man and as a statesman this is
what is being depicted in this set of
passages so we get to see these these
startling contrast between
how rule reveals the the human being
behind the ruler how it shows the
character of the person
why people in fact take on
rulership so those are some of the main
ideas but you can also say that running
throughout the entire thing of course
stoic philosophy
lots and lots of
stoic teachings
little
applications
and even practices coming in for example
the ending chapter the view from above
right which is
a practice that modern stoics have named
but which comes from marcus aurelius
take a bird's-eye view of the world its
endless gatherings and ceremonies
countless journeys in both storm and
calm and the transformation of things
coming to be
being and then ceasing to be now that's
only an abbreviated version but it gives
you an idea about
what's going on there so those are some
of the main
ideas of the work
there are a lot of good points to this
work i'm not myself a big graphic novel
person as a matter of fact i think i
only own two this one and logic comic
which i think i may have lent out to
somebody else
so you know you're getting something
from somebody who prefers to read books
and he hasn't spent much time reading
comic books since i was
in the army over 30 years ago
i think this is great i think that it's
a very compelling
telling of the story of marcus aurelius
it's not it is about you know stoic
philosophy but it's not being didactic
in how it's presenting it it's providing
you another in a way of connecting with
it through the life of somebody
who was deeply
structured in his
motivations in his judgments in his
actions but also fell short from time to
time
by stoic philosophy marcus aurelius and
so the story itself is you know very
coherent
makes a lot of sense
beautiful beautiful graphics i do want
to
show you a few of these and hopefully
they come through well and i want to
begin
with this final
chapter the view from above the first
plate of it has
three
sections
you know marcus says go to the rising
sun for i am already setting he's dying
himself
and then
there's some
teachings and
look at these
gorgeous gorgeous drawings
illustrations they're not just drawings
they're they're paintings as well
they're illustrated right
on each of the pages
these
so you know
good symbolism
and
you know artistically
compelling beautiful drawing you in
here we see
two more as well and then here are
the final ones the owl the bird of
minerva the bird of wisdom and
the setting sun
froga is
certainly a an amazing artist and so
this is uh really quite good
it conveys i would also say this is
another good point it conveys the
complexity
of not just the history
but the commitments the decisions the
characters the relationships
of the people who are characters within
the story you know think about faustina
for example
who has to endure
slander and gossip about her
and who wants to spend more time with
marcus admires him as a human being but
realizes that he's stuck being emperor
being out on the frontiers dealing with
problems to be solved over and over and
over again we we could look at uh you
know the other emperors we can look at
the complex character of cassius who's
not just a bad guy who wants to you know
take his piece he's he's trying to
figure out what to do
and so we see a lot of this going on i
would also say another really good point
of this is that we see marcus
teaching by example and who is he
teaching he's teaching his fellow romans
he's teaching himself as well and trying
to respond to what his teachers gave him
to work with
and he's teaching us
we see marcus
having to deal with his own anger
recognizing the danger that it poses as
he sees it in other people
realizing his own failings to to deal
with it and trying to do better over
and over again showing mercy giving
people the benefit of the doubt
these are all sort of lessons that are
being taught in there and i i really
think that the appendix and the
afterword are
pretty awesome i mean
so in the appendix
um
donald tells you that one of the biggest
things that he saw marcus struggling
with is indeed anger and then he gives
you this
important passage
uh from uh
the meditations book 11
chapter 18 uh these 10 gifts of the
muses which are supposed to be healing
us of our anger and these are some you
know passages that you can read through
yourself and then you can go to the
meditations and find where they are the
afterward is really great too
he tells us depiction of roman history
in such detail always presents
challenges for example in relation to
military uniforms and equipment we
sought feedbacks on that but our
priority was to serve the story rather
than slavishly maintain historical
accuracy and then he says here's the
creative decisions we made language
we're using the language coming from
historical sources as best we can
he tells us about the sources and then
he's got a section on
creative liberties acknowledging that
yes this is not
history exactly as it happened there are
a few liberties taking place for example
avidis cassius probably wasn't made
governor of syria until around
8166 whereas we have it happening three
years earlier in 163 to simplify the
sequence of events following the death
of marcus anias
libio
he talks about controversies
that um he didn't uh get into too much
um one of these has to do with whether
marcus is a warmonger genocide engager
because of the marco manic wars and he
says listen i hope that we've shown you
that this war was pretty brutal on both
sides then the second controversy is
about marcus persecuting christians and
donald says this accusation is often
repeated on the internet even in some
books there's really no credible
evidence to suggest he was personally
responsible for such persecutions indeed
several independent pieces of evidence
suggest the contrary was true
tertullian actually calls marcus a
protector of christians
interestingly he could have mentioned
justin martyr who dedicates his apology
to marcus right as well
and then there's commodus this is
another key issue commodus is marcus's
son who is is made um you know caesar
runner-up you could say and then takes
over the empire
and um you know donald has some some
pretty clear views on why marcus chose
commodus he says this question is is
rather complex i've tried to touch on
historical details that relate to it at
various points in the stories
a lot of people wanted him to make a
modis the emperor
air appearance right and it probably
would have destroyed the empire to
switch things up quickly it could have
led to civil war to not do that so those
are some you know i would say some
really solid points about this book um
it's well researched it's uh
setting things into a very uh good
narrative for for taking all of this in
it makes sense
is there anything problematic about this
work i would say that
the answer in general is no
and there's a few things where one might
quibble a bit and say yes you kind of
did take some
liberties you made some choices
that i'm not sure i would actually
go along with
one of these has to do with here's the
image of the slave who has been cast
into the pool
of eels right and the question is well
what are these eels and and one way of
trying to make sense of this is to say
that they were
lampreys which are a type of fish that
has these you know sucker
teeth and stuff like that
the trouble is that lampreys don't
kill
people
and so
you know
explaining
this
horrible horrific
episode which the emperor augustus put
an end to
where um
vedius polio a man of enormous wealth
influence and extravagant taste kept a
spa upon stock with writhing lampreys
fattened to be served at his dinner
table the lowsome beast
clasped his mouth on the body of its
victims boring its tongue into their
flesh to drink their blood so he keeps
this this pool and he throws slaves who
displease him
in there um are they really lampreys
well
other sources tell us no
and
it's much more likely that they were
actually
eels specifically mori eels you notice
that i have seneca's
anger mercy revenge volume here and this
is from the on clemency where the story
is actually
told about this
who did not hate vedius polio more
keenly than his slaves did
for fattening his morays on human blood
and ordering those who had given some
offense to be thrown into a fish pond
filled with eels the man deserved to die
a thousand times whether to feeding
whether for feeding slaves to mores
intended to feed him in turn or for
raising eels only with the aim of
feeding them this way right and so you
know
are they more are they mores are they
lampreys
it's more likely that they were more if
the goal was to actually kill people but
again kind of a little quibble right
um another one comes up here where we
see
marcus
being
given these
rare scrolls i want you to have these
rare scrolls my son
they contain the unpublished discourses
of epictetus the philosopher is written
down by my old friend aryan take them
marcus and begin to model your life on
the teachings they contain now it's
clear that marcus
did in fact read epictetus
and you know
found him to be very helpful in
understanding stoicism
were the discourses not published by
that time or were they already
circulating
yeah you know we don't really really
know but to assert that they were
definitely unpublished yeah that's a
little bit of a
stretch
there's also kind of a conflation going
on
in the roman triumph you know this is
something where we don't have solid
historical evidence
to confirm or to
deny but here's what happened so you
know marcus and his his brother are
coming back lucius and i
rode in triumph through the streets of
rome as imperial slaves stood at our
backs whispering memento mori in our
ears
look towards your death and remember you
are mortal remember you must die
um fathers of our country they're saying
we knew it not that day but along his
hall of parthian slaves and treasurer
luther had brought something back death
right so
now memento mori is a phrase that does
get used by modern day stoics it is not
one as far as we know
that actually originates
with the stoics
the earliest attestations of something
like that are in tertullian
who's a christian author and says that
you know an emperor would have his slave
tell him you know memento
but not memento mori memento
meaning remember be mindful of the fact
that you are a human being and therefore
you will die
again kind of a quibble you know um
could marcus have had somebody doing
that yes but it's a little bit
inaccurate to frame it as saying memento
mori right remember death or remember
that you must die
but these are all pretty minor points
and i don't think they detract at all
from the book as a whole
do i recommend this book i do in fact
recommend it unqualifiedly i think it's
a great book for everybody to have even
if you know stoic philosophy quite well
you've been practicing and studying it
for years you will definitely get
something out of seeing
marcus aurelius the great stoic emperor
being depicted in the way that he is
with the the gorgeous illustrations
and the very you know well thought out
storytelling and
narrative i would like to show you
something
from it those of you who already have
read aurelius's meditations or those of
you who may be about to do that
we find him engaging in that in the book
so the book is in the book right
meanwhile at carnatum i searched my
thoughts who will guide me now
well if i can no longer speak or even
write letters to you rusticus the best
of my masters i must become my own tutor
write to myself
say something to my
self and we see
the very first part of book two say to
yourself at the start of each day i will
meet with meddling ungrateful violent
treacherous envious and unsociable
people they are prone to all these
defects because they lack the knowledge
of what is good and what is bad this is
the very beginning of book two of the
meditations so we get that depicted here
i highly recommend this and i'm just
going to stop here with that
recommendation saying awesome book you
should check it out
you